so time for the press preview then a
first look at what is on the front pages
of tomorrow's papers time to see what's
making those headlines with the daily
mirror columnist susie boniface and the
deputy editor of the jewish chronicle
jake wallace simons they're going to be
with us from now until just before
midnight evening to both we'll chat in a
moment let's see those front pages
though first of all starting with the
mail carrying the news that the queen
has been told by doctors to rest for the
next two weeks and not attend any public
engagements
the mirror also leads with the queen
being told to take it easy but has said
her majesty aims to be at the cenotaph
for remembrance day
the ft leads with the french president
emmanuel macron saying the uk's
credibility is on trial over the fishing
route
the telegraph accuses the french of
wanting to punish the uk for brexit
well ahead of cop 26 the eye has an
exclusive interview with boris johnson
in which he describes the climate summit
as the last chance to save the planet
at the guardian also leading with that
cop 26 and prime minister saying if we
don't act now it will be too late
the daily express quotes prince charles
saying it is critical that we change the
way we live to stop climate change
but according to the times those pleas
for cooperation could be falling on deaf
ears when it comes to the chinese
government
and i'm joined by susie boniface and
jake wallace simons great to see you
this friday evening and some worrying
news about the queen front page of many
of the papers including the mirror queen
told rest for two weeks uh susie we were
told wendy a few days ago that she was
resting up for a few days now it's a
couple of weeks and she's missed three
very significant uh engagements um what
do you make of it
um i can understand the palaces and
perhaps the queen's reluctance to um be
too sort of public about
uh what appears to be a fairly minor
health problem because it leads to royal
correspondence having a fit of the
vapors and sticking things all over the
front page like this
um but i think if it had been you know
they haven't helped themselves by
misleading the royal press back a bit
but i think if it was
genuinely serious
um we would all know about it it
wouldn't be being kept a secret and the
royal family would be gathering around
her and so on so this is just a 95 year
old lady who is still working let's
remember
um being told to just stick to desk
duties which is absolutely fair enough
and we have seen her doing exactly that
in the last day or so the queen
carrying out uh duties at her desk over
over the computer rather than in person
uh jake the palace keen to show the
world that she is uh still okay uh she's
still managing to do a little bit of
work but sensibly taking it easy
that's right i mean i think that the
thing about this is that the longer it
goes on um the more concerned people are
inevitably going to be
and for the royal household um and their
messaging people
balance is to be struck between the
queen's privacy and not panicking people
if it is minor and then the sort of
unnecessary concern that we're going to
be that's going to be created amongst
the population by not telling people
what's wrong with her um and that's a
difficult balance to strike and i do
feel that um if this does carry on very
much longer i think that they will need
to come clean about what's been wrong
with the queen in some way shape or form
but people will know what they're
dealing with and there isn't that room
for fevered speculation about what might
be happening which might not be actually
justified
yeah um well we wish we wish her well
and of course she'll want to be at the
cenotaph when she in a couple of weeks
and uh taking precautions now in order
that she can do that let's move on then
to uh the other big story this evening
front page of the ft and this sort of
increasing row
over uh fishing and jake president
macron has said that the uk's
credibility is on trial it's remarkable
this isn't it a row over a small number
of licenses for a small number of boats
that is threatening to turn into a
full-blown trade war what what do you
think of it jake
well it strikes me that president macron
is being very very vocally
and uh and very strong and adamant in
making a point about what you rightly
saying a small number of phishing
licenses
which itself is a very small
quantity of the french economy which
itself is a tiny amount of the overall
eu concern
and to me i mean it does seem to uh
belie the fact that there is a an
election campaign going on in france
we're six months away from the french
french election and
france moving to the right have been the
big story of the election campaign so
far it does feel to me as if um
president macron is taking every
opportunity he can to bang the drama to
communicate to his own constituency that
he's uh taking this very seriously and
standing up for standing up for french
rights and perhaps using the uk is a bit
of a hunchback
and uh susie it's not just uh president
macron the french prime minister
is at it as well uk must be punished for
brexit uh he's saying uh it's the front
of the daily telegraph i mean this war
of words is sort of ramping up even
though boris johnson is saying we're
we're still besties with france
well it's being ramped up by headlines
like this because when you actually see
what the french prime minister has
written it isn't actually calling for
britain to be punished at all what he's
written is that there is inevitable
damage and he wants it to be clear that
if you leave the european union that
damage ensues that's a bit different to
punishment which is an intentional you
know penalization of someone um but it
does go to show that on both sides of
the channel domestically fishing is a
really
totemic issue for voters macron's facing
an election boris johnson's got low
popularity ratings here at the moment it
does neither of them any harm at home to
stoke this up and ramp it up they've got
their favorite um media here on this
side of the channel ramping up for them
quite nicely it is a small part of our
economy it's obviously very important if
you're one of the fishermen and it's
just a great pity that they're being
used in this way by their politicians
who have had
years
five years to get their
ducks in a row when it comes to who has
the right to go where we all should have
known what was happening everyone should
be absolutely clear to not have it clear
five years on is gross
irresponsibility on behalf
of the government is saying it is it is
very clear that they're issuing the
licenses as the as the uh uh uh the
agreement um uh uh sorted out and it's
not clear to the fishermen that's the
trouble and the fishermen you know that
one of the criteria for saying that you
have the right to a license is to have
gps data showing you've historically
been to that place not every boat's got
the same kind of data not every boat's
got the right kind of data so
bureaucracy just tearing it all apart
and if it means that the fishermen
english or french
are going to places they think they
should go
and are getting impounded or in trouble
for not having the right paperwork to be
there then it's not clear enough and
we've had five years to sort this out
this is a failure of government and the
fact they're blaming each other just
shows that they're probably both
um jake how do you think this is going
to play out of the g20 we're hearing
there will be a brush by between boris
johnson and emmanuel macron can they can
they sort this out do you think before
tuesday's deadline when things could uh
get nasty
well i think that uh luckily from from
the british point of view this doesn't
do boris any favors at all the last
thing that he needs now with cop26 and
with kovid and with inflation here at
home with soaring fuel prices and all
the other headaches he's got the last
thing he needs uh is a row with the
french however as i mentioned i think
that the french seem to be behaving in a
way that uh that suggests that it's in
their interest to ramp up this round i
mean as suzy mentioned you know many
many years of negotiation went into this
and the
eventual agreement that was arrived at
did
allow for friction of this sword for
disputing the disagreements and
providing a framework for resolving
those things if we look at the lessons
the french prime minister sent to us to
von d lyon and he wasn't appealing for
those frameworks to be for the
investigation to be launched but he was
appealing for european public opinion to
be made aware
that leaving the european union is
damaging and that sells seem to me too
tantamount to a request for punishment
and so i feel that really as the french
who have more to gain out of this
confrontation than the british and so
all really is in their course at the g20
okay we'll stay with the front of the
daily telegraph but look at a different
story susie this is about mortgage
lenders pulling their best deals
mortgages could cost
double over all the concerns that there
are at the moment about inflation
well because of inflation uh it's widely
predicted that the bank of england is
going to have to put up the base rate
and when that happens obviously banks
want you to tie into a mortgage for a
certain for as long as possible and as
high rate as possible so if the rates
are going up they're saying that the
two-year fixed rate what's happening in
the immediate future may well go up from
one percent to two percent but this
prediction is coming from some estate
agents
so although it's probably accurate this
is going to happen it's probably being
communicated to us by people who'd like
to sell you a house now
good point um jake a quick thought from
you on this before we move on
well i think it's just it's just more
pain for the british consumer we've seen
uh we've you know we've seen inflation
you've seen as i mentioned fuel prices
going up uh we've seen the highest tax
burden in 70 years uh from a touring
government that's supposed to be
committed according to ishitunak towards
reducing the tax burden and the size of
the state and then the latest
manifestation of it is this interest
rate very high on mortgages so bad news
for us as we try to get rid of kobed and
to move on